morning Millennials welcome back to the
morning just we are live in in studio
live for Monday morning it's Monday
morning
it's morning turn into a setup yeah
thank you were like like just attention
Reza do something cool
live from Monday morning it's the
warning Jost there live from the morning
toast it's Monday morning no no no live
from New York from New York it's morning
to us that works too
or live from New York it's Monday
morning like oh but what about where's
the branding I don't know
anyways whatever well just so happy to
be here you guys we had the most
treacherous weekend which is such a
shame because we'll always look back on
the weekend as pure Treach when in
reality was actually great time but
that's all forgotten you know it's like
when we went to Nashville and killed it
on our partnership with Access Hollywood
for the CMA red carpet and I know anyone
remember that because all I remember is
the divine diversion being diverted to
Pittsburgh and never getting home and
you know what people don't say about the
divine version what they don't tell you
it was like was it even divine no not at
all no I think we're putting such a
Hollywood spin on it no ours I'm
concerned there were no hookups no like
no marriages you know we did we did
experience like an amazing hotel that
when I am going back to Pittsburgh for
my show in a few weeks I will be staying
at the Fairmont for sure um it was
really nice and they hooked it up but
remember that pasta that we got oh that
was like supposed to be red it turned
out white because of all the cheese yeah
it might have been hair yes like
whatever we were not so divinely
diverted on our trip home Saturday we
hit the town the town hit us back Friday
night after my show Austin is a spot
like we didn't even get to debrief
because so much happen but I loved
Austin it's amazing it's an amazing city
and it's so like steamy it's what you
type of city like you dream of and
you're like oh it exists you know right
and then just like another element is
that they have Whataburger
yes and Jackie had her first water
burger even though she's vegetarian I
had Whataburger oh really yeah it may be
in Olivia's first oh it probably was
whatever I was just wanting everyone to
experience might my true love of water
burger
here's some interesting facts about the
24 hour water burger in Austin there's
an armed guard which actually felt
pretty safe because it was a bunch of
hooligans running around you know yeah
they had a chocolate shake delicious
we also got the cinnamon button that we
had ordered when we in Dallas like two
weeks ago and it never came so we really
needed to try it and in the midst of us
trying the cinnamon cinnamon bun I mean
it was what I ordered it was Jenny so I
wondered like a chain sandwich Jackie
doesn't eat meats like she ordered this
Cinnabon maybe like now that we're out
of austin like you'll see how wrong you
were so out of the goodness of her heart
she said Margo you oughta bite
sure I mean you know when you're eating
a cinnamon roll you obviously pick
around pick around til you get to the
center the best part so Jackie had
picked a little bit Margo was supposed
to pick a little bit more and Margo I've
never seen anything like it
she took her thumb and index finger
nails and she slipped her - [ __ ] claws
into the center of the cinnamon bond not
even gracefully like meanwhile ruining
the entire thing on the way snatch learn
it it was so unbelievably disrespectful
yeah and you see that now yeah but like
you'd think two days later you get over
it
no that's how incredibly weird it was
like your reaction rice like oh so so
[ __ ] up but you think we're gonna care
about your sweet cinnamon snatch it but
yeah when you're sober
I just sober eyes do you've something to
show lies whatever that thing says I'm
good you have nothing just about no
regrets no regrets here no I got the
center of the Cinnabon for you how was
it
it was um not as good as I wanted it it
was like really really good but not as
good as it looked
yeah it looked insane yeah well I got a
chicken sandwich and a chocolate
milkshake and the chocolate milkshake
was so good and then me and Margo get
back to the room and we're going to
sleep but like for some reason we were
like super awake and we were like
talking so much and she was like by the
way you're such a freak for ordering its
chocolate shake look what do you mean
she's like vanilla I'm like what it was
just a weird insult and like one that's
like it's an age-old question vanilla or
chocolate it's not like such a weird
thing to do no and also like when it
comes to a milkshake in general I think
I'm depends on my mood but sometimes
more vanilla person but for a milkshake
vanilla is just a little too milky
there's I agree you need something to
throw off the milk no it's like there's
no flavor this drinking milk out of a
straw I couldn't agree more Jackie that
is such an astute and genius absurd
as always thank you well anyways the
show dirty jeans sorry no you can't say
but it was so great no actually I can't
say it because everyone knows like
whatever I get offstage and I want to
cry because like it was so bad Margo
said it was the best show ever then I
got upstage him like that was awesome
Margot was like honest it was right you
know so we never have a really good
gauge but this time I got off just
feeling empowered and I was like I hope
these [ __ ] agree with me and I think
everyone was on the same page it was
really a great job it was really a great
show the Osteen's were so late so they
they brought it all and so overall it
was such a great weekend in Austin and
we we're on 1 o'clock flight home we
were ready great and get home at 5
o'clock
perfect leave early we've been talking
all the way to the airport we were
talking the whole time about how genius
we are forgetting on this flight we got
old 5 o'clock Saturday we don't have to
do anything all night with shower we
unpack we'll be in bed by 10:00 like we
woke up in Austin at 10:00 we had a full
breakfast and it's just like everything
was going our way the flight is on time
we SROI it in we found the best new
invention out there which is a robotic
barista coffee it was called a bro guy
oh yeah bro yo something some think it
was a robot coffee vending machine and I
you know I don't trade coffee
I got an iced caramel macchiato and I
was like a living it was so good you
could like order it's really cool it's
the future and I'm excited the future
looks good to me
yeah me too I know people are like
saying robots they're taking our jobs
but like and I welcome this robot I
welcome this robot it's like a robots
not gonna get a hair in your drink and
I'm all about it so we stroll onto the
plane with our matching coffee cups like
ready we sit we're situational term was
one o'clock we took off at 1:10 that
never happens right we're up in the sky
it was a little bit of a bumpy takeoff
but you know what it's plane and I was
smelling something really smelly and I
was like oh my god I'm seated next to
like a smelly man it was it was the
smell of like not Bo but just like
uncleanliness you know and it was
bothering me but like not to the point
where I cared enough because I was just
so happy to be going home and I guess I
wasn't the only person he smelled too
because the pilot comes on like right
after we reached 30,000 feet I got Wi-Fi
he comes on the plane and he's like
comes on the mic and he says yeah we're
getting that smells kind of smells like
socks I'm like yes I'm spunky think it
means that air conditioning is is
leaking or the oil is has leaked
into the air-conditioning and it's
really not safe for us to go all the way
to New York so we're gonna head around
and go back to us in and I was like are
you [ __ ] kidding me
well then so let's just risk it this is
inconvenient but we're always just like
watching TV I need to go back to Austin
and then all of a sudden all the TV's
turn off the whole all the TVs turn off
on the plane and my window was down but
it felt like we were just going straight
ahead fast like we're not turn not even
that's so bumpy you can feel a turn and
we're not turning so I finally put my
window down like you can see a bench and
now when I looked at the map on flight
aware it shows how it was like a
confusing it was like a figure eight hmm
but we finally unpacked to Austin but it
was therefore very scary I was you know
saying my prayers like getting ready
breathe myself but we landed safely and
then then the torture really ensued
right because they said this point was
like 145 the Delta app said 245 then it
said three o'clock 2015 then it said
5:30 and we were like [ __ ] and this was
the only flight out of Austin to New
York that day that was non-stop so we
didn't know whether it was best to like
wait or hop on another flight a
connecting flight and thankfully we rise
into your a sub guy the grace of God we
ran into a guardian angel in the Austin
Airport by the name Olivia creating she
just moved back to Austin I totally
forgot and she was there working in the
Sky Lounge and we were sitting in the
sky that she was being so helpful like
telling us all you know the backend
secrets of all like the ferry flight and
like what could go like what they're
doing for our flight they're bringing
over a completely empty flight like from
Atlanta to give us a new plane but like
what that means and how it could go
wrong and it was really like playing in
insiders yeah but she was he like
totally straight with us and like we had
like three different backup plans it was
so good to like see her and catch up
uh-huh and also like have this guiding
light it was truly in such a dark time
it was a bright light it was a bright
light like it was definitely the best
the silver lining of the day yeah and
all the rice krispie treats and the
coffee vending machine yeah but we wound
up eating so [ __ ] much it was it was
the only thing to do it was the only
thing to do but it's so disappointing
because I was like so ready to have like
a decently a decent day we got like good
snacks for the plane ready to go I would
have landed a five had dinner and like
been okay and
I just like I felt like like a binge
drink like a binge ate all day it was
and it was painful honestly I had [ __ ]
burger and cheese fries oh I had a
veggie burger and cheese fries we did
not stop eating but you know that's in
times of despair like it's the only
thing that makes you feel like a little
bit better no I just I knew then we were
tender oh my god did this ever happen to
you and it happens to me every weekend I
don't know I always just assumed it's
from either drinking or just like
dancing moving muscles and I'm sore but
like where you become tender like if you
press down on your skin it hurts
no I only get breast tenderness around
once a month oh so I was we were in the
car on the way home and Margo was saying
oh my gosh because we ate so much like
we're gonna you ever get in pain I was
like I get that pain but it's not
because of eating I had no clue but it's
like every time I get that pain yes I'd
eaten a lot but I've also drink a lot
dance a lot be traveling I don't get
that maybe it's cuz I don't even know I
get it like I get it all the time I
think it really an extent where like I
really [ __ ] like it's unnecessary to eat
that much I feel it like in my skin like
I can't touch my skin without hurting
you ever heard of love okay well I'm
glad I guess and I asked my friends
yesterday if it happens nothing like
they didn't say yes I think just like an
us thing yeah I got to see you guys you
didn't say yes but if anyone else
experiences this we don't know if it's
from the eating like I we have like
isolate we have to isolate but I don't
think it's from the drinking because
it's like I've had weekend's where I've
drink and more than that but I haven't
eaten that much in having I know I
haven't been tender well I just prefer
to tender yeah yeah so we made it home
at midnight midnight it was such torture
but like there's really no feeling
compared to climbing into your own bed
after a long hard day like and then also
having your son between your legs that
was the only thing I was a marine but I
got though he was missing for me huh but
I got into my bed and I was like this is
heaven like yeah this was worth it maybe
the plane did go down and now I'm in
heaven
yeah honestly but I don't care
regardless because I'm happy right
because heaven is anywhere it's
beautiful so thanks to all the Osteen's
who came out me and Margaret headed back
on the road Wednesday night we're going
to Portland there are very few tickets
left Seattle sold-out Vancouver some
seats left so head over to Grove [ __ ]
calm that's Vancouver and Portland
that's still have tickets left
can't you see on my West Coast scenes I
forgot that Portland is considered
the west coast yeah a six-hour flight
still six hour
oh that's a good question call it's just
it's like the West it might be a so West
okay we're gonna want to the wild wild
west that's really cool six hour flight
you know that charge yesterday I watched
five movies which is crazy what do you
guys watch i watch the new season of
shameless and I have I have an update
for you about friends because zach has
been watching and I've been allowing him
to like watches this maybe that's
annoyed like I'm not in the mood to
argue about it no I'm not arguing about
it I said I there were a few times that
I chuckles oh you're having the bed
effect okay yeah I miss having to bed i
Chuck knew I'm still not about it and I
have a call and it's the opposite of
yours which is that the person who ruins
the show for me it is now is Ross a lot
of people feel that way but they're just
uneducated and stupid it's fast with his
doofus II way of being and what season
is he on Rachel's pregnant
oh so you're really far along alright
yeah we're just saying I'm just kind of
in there I understand I hear what you're
saying it's just like what someone like
uneducated in the franchise would say
you know no it's just someone who has
like a clear set of eyes and hasn't been
like Stockholm Syndrome no Ross is Russ
is the most controversial character on
the show because people either feel my
way about him or your way about him and
like my opinion of him it's like just
watching him for a small he's most
talented actor on the show like he
couldn't like he when he was playing
Robert Kardashian I'm like why is Ross
Geller here like he's so believable as
Ross Geller that it's almost detrimental
to his career no I think Ross Geller is
actually ruining Robert Kardashian for
me
yeah and he's just literally the
funniest one on the chair like I gotta
say I don't want to go check it cuz like
I know I'm right so far I think the
funniest one on the show based on what
I've seen it's Joey
okay know that it's the lamest answer
Monica I thought she was gonna say well
no one would say Monica I thought she
was gonna say Phoebe and then I would
have had to let some respects that
answer no Phoebe's beanies okay but I
know like she I heard no air like
supposed to be this like the funny in
Joey's like the most low-hanging fruit
like duh like that's what I would think
but he he did her said a few say maybe I
was that like see laughing aren't many
petty I'm just keeping an open mind like
I don't think I'll ever like Stan like
you do but I'm keeping an open mind
my man taught you this we fall asleep
okay it's really great
that's what happens like Ben was like
not friends and then he would be like
the show sucks
ya know I haven't gotten there yet but
um I'm just keeping an open mind
that's what pores open it's always what
I said I would do and that is that
that's what you said
so the doors open that's the update I
watched all girl [ __ ] was it good it was
really good um I will do a whole
analysis
I could always nitpick overall it's a
great movie and it was very endearing
and it made me follow Serena carpenter
on Instagram Sabrina carpenter for year
I since I am free I like a little ice I
must have I unfollowed and now I'm ready
to refile oh um so at the end of this
episode
did you watch Kardashians and did you
watch oh you don't watch Potomac
no okay also did you watch the roast of
Alec Baldwin no but I want to I didn't
know tell us I have a lot of thoughts on
all three things so we'll get to it at
the end I watched four different
hallmark movies it was a great day
that's all that's what we were hoping
for so hustlers
oh yeah Margo it gave the snitch to them
approval yeah it was so good except the
only problem that I had is that I just
don't like Constance way why now that
was the whole movie net was she and
knowing that we know about her now how
can you did you see that there's like
Oscar buzz for Jennifer yeah um and I
fully support it because I things I
don't run it I don't know I don't know
JLo but like now this is that's just
this is just how I see Huracan yeah you
look at a pre JLo like you're yeah but
like it she looked amazing and I have to
say Lilly Reinhardt was so good Lilly
Reinhardt is an amazing it's an amazing
actor acting is a little too good for
Riverdale yeah I was shocked and the
Keke Palmer was great I mean I just
[ __ ] them for anything kinky P Q so
very much what happens I know was she
good oh my god she was amazing wait
also speaking of watch happens live she
was with Giselle Bryan yeah and Giselle
on the Potomac reunion one hour before
watch outside
confirm that she's back with her
ex-husband they had been divorced for 12
years but they co-parent really well and
he is like a huge civil rights activist
like really famous started a church his
name is Jamal Bryant and I was on
Twitter and there was a Sunday service
yesterday streaming at Jamal Bryant's
Church so Kanye was there with Jamal and
like how cool for gizelle that's really
cool and she was from tomorrow at Dave
Chapelle right confirming now that it
was the two of them that we're friends
with her ex-husband yeah yeah because we
were watching Jay Chou for like
earth time and I was like I hadn't
noticed that someone in the front row
looked familiar I was like doesn't that
look like that housewife from Potomac it
was before you were watching and you
were like yeah I thought the same thing
and then Bravo toaster scenes
yeah I thought that that it was her and
Jamal so so fun back and just exciting
for Giselle though like now she's gonna
be like a Kardashian associate it you
know yeah like she plays her cards cards
right he's very smart like she will take
this opportunity
I wonder if Kim was there oh no I don't
know whatever so we will be recapping
all of that at the end of the show but I
actually I want to see hustlers this
week because it feels very like relevant
it is and also Liz oh and cardi babe
like it was just like the her flute was
in it
she had the buck up okay okay she flew
did so I should be flute it's absolutely
fluted we'll go this week oh my god okay
but without further ado here are the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast yeah that is true
but in case you're you know maybe you're
on keto or you're not eating toast you
don't have any bread in the kit in the
kitchen and you want to whip something
up for breakfast well you try daily
harvest laughing do you like that side
right in somewhere has been great but
now we are itching to get back into our
routine after all the barbecues and
eating out during vacation we're ready
to get back into our eating habit that's
good for us but finding time to look for
recipes go to the grocery store and meal
prep makes it overwhelming and that's
what's great about daily harvest
honestly I've never really these just
something more like the hardest thing
ever is decided to cook a meal like
going to the grocery store making all
the dishes like taking six hours to get
it down and then like 30 seconds to eat
it and then you're left with the dishes
for like a month
mm-hmm daily harvest makes it easier
than ever to get back into the habit of
eating more fruits and vegetables with
thoughtfully sourced chef crafted fruits
that can be prepared in less than five
minutes fill your box with more than 65
different options like ready to blend
smoothies hearty soups and savory
harvest bowls everything stays fresh in
your freezer until you're ready to eat
it each daily harvest cup takes one step
to prepare with room for customization
you can add your favorite milk to a
smoothie and blend it or you can heat a
harvest Bowl up and top it with an
avocado or a fried egg all of daily
harvest ingredients are sourced and
selected from a maximum nourishment and
peak season flavor
taylean harvest is the quickest and most
convenient way to eat a delicious and
nutritious meal or snack whenever you
are at your desk or studying or on the
go you know as we're we're such studies
go to daily harvest calm and enter
Cotto's to get $25 off your first box
that's promo code toast to $25 off your
first box at daily harvest com daily
harvest com code toast for $25 off sign
on and stay fit
yo ya know that's where I need to be
this week the daily harvest sort of
fleek take those babies out of the
fridge and yeah go yep okay first you're
a big news of the weekend I would say
Felicity Huffman has been sentenced to
prison Felicity Huffman and
oscar-nominated actress and star of
Desperate Housewives will serve 14 days
in jail for her role in the largest
college admissions scandal in US history
Huffman 56 will report to prison on
October 25th and the Bureau of Prisons
will decide the facility the US District
Judge Indira Kewanee also world that
Huffman will serve one year probation
pay a thirty thousand dollar fine and
performed 250 hours of community service
Huffman pleaded guilty in May to one of
conspiracy to commit mail fraud and
honest services mail fraud what's honest
services male friend assuming you were
honest I I don't know but I'm so shocked
by this well yeah I can't believe she
actually got sentenced to prison and
that just does not bode well for the Roy
Laughlin cuz Felicity Huffman was the
one who like cooperated she pled guilty
like she she seemed like she was like
wanting to had the process over with
like not drag out a long trial and she
was the one who paid less and like her
crime was like less yes so it's like
this is the punishment for her crime
while following the rules of like you
know playing the game right so what her
lawyers told her so I don't more ease
punishment if she's found guilty will be
so much more for two different reasons
but I'm feeling like Lori's gonna fight
this tooth and nail like if
what's-his-name Frank Underwood
Kevin Jeffery gallier Kevin Spacey thank
you Kevin Spacey all the all the cards
were stacked against him and they
couldn't prove his case and he got off
if Kevin Spacey can get off like I think
Lori Loughlin can get off like you she
got I think she they find a loophole
like with her lawyers like she probably
has the best lawyers in the world like
she might be able to fight this I don't
know I kind of I'm actually glad that
she's gonna fight it to see if maybe she
can't like maybe there's no it's not all
there I think
Lori Loughlin like she's gonna go to
prison like you do you think she'll get
like anything special or like she's
actually gonna have to sit for 14 days
Oh Felicity Huffman um I think she won't
I think she probably won't serve before
he knees because like you could probably
get off for good behavior right good
behavior for spike how can you prove
your good behavior so quickly I know but
like also I think you guys could do 14
days in prison
it didn't I if I was going to like uh
like a nice prison I think so yeah well
we don't know which person she's going
to yet and a lot of times with these
short sentences sentences they don't
actually wind up serving like Khloe
Kardashian she's like we're crowding
overcrowding and stuff but um I feel
like she must be so relieved right now
because I finally it's like situation
going into prison what are you doing but
she she pled guilty she this is her
punishment like for so long it's been
the unknown of what it's gonna be okay
now it's working he's like she can
handle that obviously she'll feel so
much better when it's over but like I
feel as though the storm is starting to
pass like she'll be done with this you
know by my birthday and like then the
world is her oyster yeah look she's
she's a convicted felon but I think
she's ever going to like work again yes
I really do because I think anyone who's
like so hard on her for like this crime
like I don't know I if I were a director
I would happily she's a wonderful
actress I think people are on her side
she's doing about this in the most
likable way yeah especially juxtaposed
to Lauri Lockean even though like when
Lori Loughlin is all said and done like
I would happily swatch her in hallmark a
movie again
no but hallmark is so love our quote
higher no but I'm saying as a hallmark
that you were like right like if you're
listening which like apparently they do
ah I would I would I would forget you
know Felicity Huffman already has edge
so this just like really like improves
her street cred
you know I'm Felicity Huffman is still
in movies right now like she filmed
stuff that's coming out right now like
um that one that'll let me like other
hood okay oh yeah like that's still
playing out by the time that that's over
like she'll be ready for her next flick
yeah it's really must be a good feeling
that she got this over with yeah and
then it's not so so bad yeah it's a man
big Judy like it's over you know ya know
and so I'm happy for cuz I think the
anticipation that's the worst and the
unknown that's the worst and fortunately
she's a tough cookie Lynn
scoff oh yeah these piece of cake yeah I
think she can handle it yeah I'm even if
like she's not Lynette Scavo like in her
regular life like she's an actress she
can act like an average that's so true
you know and now it's just like I want
to know more about her husband William H
Macy like yeah how he wanted to say the
real test completely out of it and like
for Lori Loughlin both of them are being
prosecuted William HMAC is not being
prosecuted and he's totally fine he
wasn't really on the emails like he just
he must be like less involved as a
parent no shame and he got off unscathed
but he also like didn't I feel like
there's gonna be trouble there yes I'm
good well I'm just now starting the new
season of shameless and like I can't
think of Frank Gallagher now is anything
other than lettuce godless husband you
know oh really yeah is it taking the
show it kind of it's just cuz they'd be
like in the public so much like usually
between shameless seasons like I never
hear from William H Macy like he stays
at home you know yeah but now he's just
been like in at the courthouse
paparazzi it's top of mind for me yeah
also since Laurie is like going to trial
chill probably have a jury and like
anything can happen like OJ got off for
murder like anything can happen right
and then why they're not so cutting
Dracula in Boston right that's where the
trial Jessi Smollett yeah did you say
Smalley a musky smell it like I don't
think it happened her trials gonna be in
Boston it's at crap yeah so like do you
know anyone who's in Bosnia like might
be called for jury duty
um I think some toasters will be on that
jury oh they're gonna get exempt because
they're too involved know if you are
like a toaster and you are coming up for
jury duty in the next few weeks in
Boston like honestly it sticks their
stick with it yeah you could be landing
the role with a lifetime everyone on the
OJ Simpson um Jerry wrote a successful
New York Times bestselling book like
stay this could be your opportunity big
break but also pay attention I mean
really in jury duty they do coach you
like to be ready to be a juror
like even if I felt some type of way
about us uh Bernie and I wound up being
on the jury which wouldn't happen but
like I really felt like I wanted to be
unbiased you know and I was gonna listen
to an actually think I would be a great
juror like that's what we do on the show
every would be an absolutely terrified
I'd be a terrible we have the judge and
jury on the show yeah no actually
you think it would be a great juror
maybe even a rural one hmm but the urban
fervor yes the thing I don't know if you
got there buddy Bourbon I don't know I
could get it
honestly I just think I would be such a
bad juror like the long hours and like
it would drive me nuts I would just say
he was guilty so I could go home you
know yeah but you're getting paid and
you're getting paid from your work like
you get waiting for jury duty and you
get double income that's sure but it's
like four times harder than I normally
work I guess so yeah so it's not enough
money that's fair I don't know I just
think I don't know somebody think about
it's something you think about if you'd
be good juror anyways it's this is crazy
though like I can't believe that the
judicial process is going so quickly
yeah let's that never happen does this
all started in well so you have the
right to a speedy trial as the person
being accused of a crime so for someone
like Lori Loughlin she would obviously
want to get this over with really
quickly yeah but that's what that was
like the whole r.kelly documentary like
he has the right to a speedy trial but
he kept delaying it so we could like
make music and make more money and like
you would also think he would want to
get it over with quickly well yeah like
a rational person would but I don't
think in that scenario we're working
with a rational person yeah but like our
Kelly got off there's literally a
videotape he got off I I have hope for
Lori Loughlin I'm just saying it's
actually a good point
like that's all I'm saying is what I've
been traditional I used to miss flow
it's not so cut and dry you know and
like I think she is she's got the best
she's got the best in the biz and
they're gonna see it through and like
you know it's it's interesting from a
viewers perspective to see both
scenarios play out right so that's that
okay but the risk of you not getting oh
of you not winning not winning is worth
just for just going to jail for 40 days
and I wouldn't be 14 days but no I don't
know but if she had pled guilty and
Lori's crimes she played $500,000 so
whatever the ratio is right there to 500
yeah so 14 to X yeah it was just like
I'll do 250 days a year and a half
that's a long [ __ ] time yeah let's
write it out let's write it out I don't
know it doesn't sound so crazy to me
anymore also like Felicity's punishment
is pretty like big right because it's
the 14 days in jail then it's like also
after gel is what's torture yeah gear of
probate
200 hours of community service and the
$30,000 fine and like I could have seen
like just that being the punishment what
a thing no that's just like the side the
cherry on top
yeah that's just some ass potatoes yeah
maybe 466 days pretty close 466 Wow cool
next up Zooey Deschanel moves on with
property brothers star Jonathan I'm so
glad we're talking about this incredibly
[ __ ] weird situation one week after
Joey Deschanel show me a picture which
brother is it um this one don't they all
look the same
is it true or Jonathan Jonathan I get
them confused are they twins
yeah but like what they look kind of
different one of them is a contractor
and one of them is the real estate agent
who doesn't do anything who comes in at
the beginning at the end of every
episode mm-hmm
can you Google which one's the
contractor and which ones I just I
thought I thought that the the real
estate guy got married last year but
that kind of looks like him um we'll get
to it okay
one week after Zooey Deschanel and her
husband Jacob
Pecha Nick announced they were splitting
up news broke that the actress actresses
dating property brothers star Jonathan
Scott quote its new but they are having
a lot of fun together a source told
People magazine on Friday photos
captured by Hollywood Life also showed
at Deschanel and Scott holding hands
this week Deschanel and Scott also
filmed a carpool karaoke segment earlier
this year alongside Scott's brother and
HGTV co-star Drew and Deschanel actress
sister Emily well is that a man I don't
know this she now this she which brother
is this Jonathan is a contractor
Jonathan is a contractor okay he's a
cuter one and like definitely the richer
one cuz he does more work yeah and the
other brother nicely fifty-fifty they're
brothers Jackie literally Jonathan it's
like on his back ripping tile out of the
floor while Drew was like fake showing
houses to clients that like our actors
you know I think they're 5050
this shouldn't be they should be though
cuz then it gets too murky yeah I guess
this is just such a weird story like
with so many weird layers like the first
beings that we use you know is the
weirdest girl ever and like she's just
like quirky and Q and like I honestly
like don't sad and the property brothers
are just like this it's just too much
for me honestly like this is sorry
overload for me like this is like two
people I owe I don't care about poppy
that brothers I don't care about
Zooey Deschanel so like I'm happy that
like two people I don't care about that
on each other you know they're not like
taking up space teachers that I do care
about and it seems like other people are
gonna be excited about this so I'm happy
for everyone else no I think I don't
think other people are gonna be excited
I think people are genuinely confused
really like to Zoey
no offense like Jonathan Scott like he's
the hotter one like he's definitely does
really well they're all over chase like
they definitely a lot of money but she
does she I thought you were about to
argue that like he's doing I knew the
end of the day like she's a movie star
and he's reality started like the two
should really not mix but they do so
here we are they do and by the way this
is the trend Sarah and Welles walked so
Zoe and Jonathan could ride just need to
like triple check that this is the right
brother because they confuse me so much
while we're talking about reality start
seeing people way out of their league
this would be a great opportunity to
talk about the fact that Mike Johnson
went on a date with Tammy Lovato yeah
and I need to get everyone's thoughts
and feelings it's just like [ __ ] over
it
just like everyone just and you're
[ __ ] lame no everyone the lanes
snatch they're merging the lanes Billy
they have to have their turn signals on
and people are merging lanes I just like
I can I'm happy for these Hollywood Life
photos that were captured like are so
weird and staged yeah like she's like
wearing she really dresses and talks
like she's like was born in the 30s you
know yeah it's not bad
you just I'm honestly really put off by
this whole situation like I don't like
cross-pollination
like from like genres like reality you
know she's you know I just I suppose
situation I do like I don't like it no
and like so the other brother just got
married or like found a girlfriend or
something last season and they did like
a whole series about him and his new
wife like moving into a house like if
Zooey Deschanel doesn't HGTV show both
Jew Scott like you know tiling their
house like I will literally jump off the
Reg yeah no I don't think she should
start like playing in his pond but I
kind of I like it no I mean it's like
I'm happy they're happy
I didn't just sends a great message like
anything is possible you know yeah just
an in life yeah no I'm happy that
they're happy but this just seems so
incredibly odd oh for sure and
James Corden is to blame always always
um
what do you think that Demi Lovato Mike
Johnson I actually like kind of ship
them I don't have such weird feelings
about it as I do for like Tyler and Gigi
I don't know why I just think like Demi
Lovato was like thirsting hear about
your desensitized no not know it's like
Demi Lovato was like thirsting for The
Bachelor like always tweeting about it
like when two live tapings like she took
her step down into bachelor nation like
hmm we already knew she was sitting
there you know yeah but with Gigi it's
like she's a whole other world to sever
acknowledge the bachelor franchise in
her life and all of a sudden is the star
of it
yeah but definitely bought it was
humbled enough to take a seat at five
yes yeah I agree with that but you want
to know an interesting factoid Demi
Lovato has doubled the amount of
Instagram followers as gigi hadid Demi
Lovato it was like kind of like a legend
no so yet Demi Lovato is technically a
bigger star and you know that's a good
point and it's less weird double the
like Gigi is 40 we know what it is 19
because Debbie Lovato is much more
relatable like Gigi Hadid might not be
as big of a star but she's a [ __ ]
supermodel like walking on runways like
no one can even relate to that like Demi
Lovato has been open about like her
struggle with sobriety or struggle with
her weight like that's [ __ ] relatable
for sure so I just went more she's more
of a down-home check you oh that's why
this makes more sense why it doesn't
seem as weird no yeah that's why it's
less contrast she's less elitist yes I
agree with that but like you which
almost makes you forget that like she's
almost had a hundred million Instagram
followers like she's with the boys
because she's did you she's been out of
commission for over a year in terms of
music of she gets royalties
every time you say I'm happy for you no
actually she does so we should stop
saying yeah that's that's that on that
yeah I don't know why it just doesn't
seem as like crazy to me I agree on the
Jonathan Scott and Zooey Deschanel seems
crazier than Demi and John my Johnson
yeah yeah also people have been like
speculating about Jamie and Mike but now
I'm nervous because clearly that was
their first date yeah date that someone
overheard like where they were talking
about on their legs and tour how does it
work with all of that quote unquote but
now there's too much pressure
yeah only a first day they don't have
that bond to sail through all these
precious waters yeah oh and just go and
we've heard from like a bunch of people
that Mike Johnson's like kind of like
nerdy and like maybe his reason for not
being the bachelor was like his
personality isn't so great so once all
the camera lights are gone I'm like you
guys have to go on a date with someone
like to him in the bottle it might be
like man yeah yeah I don't like I'm if I
was a betting woman I'm not gonna bet on
these two no but I really did I want a
chimp I'm championing them yeah I might
bet on them just to like give them the
confidence but I know I'm gonna lose
money yeah you know but it's like it's
worth it because I'm happy for them
right you know that know that you are
exactly okay next step speaking of James
Corden James Corden responds to Bill
Maher's fat-shaming comments oh my god
this was like you know sis on sis cried
too [ __ ] loser II like privilege
these men have never had to like work
hard in their lives like everything is
just one hand is that and that I fight
like it was so like I actually loved the
argument that James Carter was making
but I just couldn't take it seriously
with like these two
[ __ ] [ __ ] like who would just to
get everything they've ever wanted you
know I know but like there's something
about James Corden that's not earring
that is so endearing and you don't think
of him as just like Oh old white man
like never had shrunk oh he fights for
the underdog but when you do get to the
root of it it is says on Cisco yeah yes
it sounds it's like Bill Maher James
Corden like straight white men like who
just like rose to fame like because
they're straight white sis men like I
just
I bet Jimmy James Corden's more than
that because he's like musical and he
goes outside the bomb and the people
think he's gay but at the end of the day
he's just as famous yes the son says
crime
[Music]
James Corden took aim at Bill Maher's
recent fat shaming comments with her a
bottle delivered on Thursday's edition
of CBS's the Late Late Show Maher host
of HBO's Real Time with Bill Maher joked
about obesity on the show last week
saying quote fat isn't a birth defect
and quote nobody comes out of the womb
needing to buy two seats on the airplane
he advocated quote fat shaming doesn't
need to end
to make a comeback oh I also just want
to say on our initial takeoff from
Austin I had the seat open next to me
behind me was snitch with the seat open
next to her behind her Birds Olivia with
a Smith C open X her like it wasn't a
bet it was too good to be true but on
the way on the second flight you guys
together quite interesting yes sir right
so any take that matter that's trippy
Courtney and cute clips from our segment
and then offered his own testimonial as
a person who has long battled weight so
Bill Maher's argument was basically like
it's like helping charity right now it's
been like a now we're living in a
culture where you know being overweight
is celebrated and if you point out the
fact that being overweight is bad for
your health like you become evil and so
in order to fix that we should bring
back fat shaming to shame fat people
into getting skinning okay yeah I only
watched James Corden's clip where he
only said the mean stuff not like the
argument about all what you just said um
but yes he is advocating for bringing
back a fat shaming as to ameliorate the
fat problem he thinks it's gonna help he
thinks it's gonna help yes I agree okay
quote James Corden there's a common and
insulting misconception that fat people
are stupid and lazy and we're not we get
it we know we know that being overweight
isn't good for us and it struggled my
entire life trying to manage my weight
and I suck at it I've had good days and
bad months quote I've basically been off
and on diets since as long as I can
remember and well this is how it's going
he pointed to himself Gordon and Marv
both produced their shows out of the
same lot television city in LA towards
the end of the eight-minute eight-minute
segment Corden take a few swipes at his
can tanker a sniper but we're not all as
lucky as Bill Maher we don't all have a
sense of superiority that burns thirty
five thousand calories a day Courtney
joked he went on to show another clip of
Maura mocking obesity could it's not
just about being able to see a doctor
it's also about being able to see your
dick I didn't catch that part but yes
this is census crime actually is
highlighting an important issue and like
I I don't disagree with James Horton
impact and I agreed that fat shaming has
not gotten anywhere that's what I was
gonna say it's um I I actually feel both
ways shockingly about this because I'm
the one hand I feel like being fat is
like the last frontier like being it's
acceptable to make fun of yes to make
fun and then also like make judgements
make decisions like hiring decisions
almost like discriminate
that people is a minority that doesn't
get any of the other like advantages oh
great but then on the other hand I feel
like it's a great time to like to be
plus-sized and like where the world is
more inclusive than it's ever been and
it's more celebrated and maybe we're not
a hundred percent there yet but we're as
close as we've ever been we are as close
as we've ever been and it definitely
like is the best time now to be
plus-sized and be overweight but it's
like only in like the magazines that we
read you know anything like that like
real life hasn't taken you know hasn't
molded itself after what you read in
like a lizzo article you know and a mean
like right now it's still like
aspirational but it's being said yes
it's like I agree you have to seek it
out sometimes but still like there are
so many now movies like it used to be
movie stars we're only like Size Zero
that's true you know typical I think
rate very listen yeah now leads like
Julian bail it it's there's more
diversity diversity and like more
visible plus-sized figures right so I
guess that's why it made the Bill Maher
thing like so much more finally making
progress in one side where it's like
that all of those things are negative
and they're encouraging people to be fat
and but I don't think it's it's one way
or the other I don't think you see
someone who's plus sizing you're like oh
now I want to gain weight no but but I
think that makes you feel better about
this [ __ ] that you're hung up on about
yourself I think Bill Maher's
like argument required a response from
James Corden now more than ever because
it's like what he's saying is rude and
damaging but it's even more damaging now
that we've actually made progress yeah
it's like trying to stymie that progress
and James Corden is just saying like
let's keep at it because by the way it's
not it's not even as good for us as you
think it is right no it's just like a
like an interesting fight like I wonder
if Lamar's gonna respond this Blume are
on the air every night or every week I
think real-time so that sounds like
every night yeah I wonder if he's gonna
respond he should I don't know but like
James Corden is just I wouldn't want to
hurt his feelings like if I said
something in James Corden like argued
against me even if I was right or
whatever like I would just be like oh my
god I'm sorry there's like if your
precious gem like James Corden like
you're an [ __ ] like James Corden
doesn't have beef with anyone like if
you google James Corden beef like
nothing until Bill Maher you know yeah
so interesting an interesting fight and
I'm always here to talk about cat
shaming you know right and it's not the
the overall message is that fat shaming
is not gonna work like fat people raise
[ __ ] right all the [ __ ] time like
having it come from Bill Maher it's not
gonna suddenly make me stop eating know
you might eat more right so it's like
okay if we want to move in a healthy
direction like let's do that in a
healthy way not in a way that changed
people and just into being skinny
because that's not gonna happen either
yeah it's just an ineffective way he was
like Bill Maher was arguing that like in
order to get rid of obesity we should be
fat shaming but what James Corden so
astutely pointed out is that shame has
never helped a fat person get skinny
yeah because they feel shame all the
time it actually probably makes it worse
100% yeah giving me remind me of tall
girl just like so is it yeah it's also
11:11 make a wish I wish ever oh my god
same I wish I could love them so I was
not what because it's not a choice you
know yeah I guess you could like fake it
til you make it but yeah how [ __ ]
hard that was just a little brilliant
point what he just said like the whole
thing that last thing like all of it oh
my god thank you just unsubscribe man
suscribe okay
next story I chose for you because if I
were you I would find the story
interesting okay friends co-creator Mark
Hofmann regrets these two pot lines Oh
interesting exactly why we laughing at
me
[Applause]
you said co-create Amada snacks are has
match left so I laughed Wow
cuz I snatch last God plus okay the one
with Marta Kauffman cigarettes burgers I
just watch where the male airs on the
play so you watch actually split it up
into three different flights
um and it's just such a [ __ ] good
movie I walked out of the theater
you're lying oh then you missed the end
which is what makes the movie so great
yeah they were like I'm this RV Liz
Gillies showed up and then I was like I
gotta go you're talking about the wrong
movie Lucille is in we're the Millers no
she's not she's the one second yes she
is no she's not who is she I don't know
she's not in it she might be an RV the
best movie I wish Liz Gillies
an RV rest in peace Robin Williams
during a 25th anniversary panel of
friends at the Tribeca TV Film Festival
on Friday the show's co-creator actually
just festival because it's TV sorry the
show's co-creator admitted there are two
plot lines she isn't too thrilled with
quote the stalker Kaufman said referring
to an episode from season three of the
beloved sitcom in which Phoebe ends up
falling for a guy named Malcolm who's
been stalking her twin sister well we
did a lot of rewriting on that to make
that work she her veil revealed Calvin
also wasn't thrilled with a plotline
from season 2 where Phoebe gets the
chickenpox and gives them to someone in
the journal ashamed Ryan who sometimes
date who she sometimes date when he's in
town while co-creator David Crane didn't
call any specific moments he commented
quote it's one of those things where I
don't watch the show at home but
occasionally if we're traveling or
whatever it will be on and sometimes
I'll see something and it'll be like wow
that actually holds up and then there
are definitely times where I'll go
really we went with that oh that's
interesting
it's said that like all their mishaps
happen around Phoebe you know like she
really was having a hard time finding
that guy who she was you know yeah very
interesante i definitely agreed that
episode where Phoebe's stalker is like
stalking her and he's like what do you
want and he thinks it was her slow like
so stupid and so weird I don't think the
Charlie Sheen chicken pox thing was that
weird but I guess Marta did so yeah and
that's a weird thing like to give
someone in the Navy chicken pox ya know
and then they're like sitting in
Monica's a partner like scratching each
other with wooden spoons it's actually
really [ __ ] stupid yeah well she
greased thank you for sharing you're
welcome
Phaethon final story um crazy story I
need to pause because John Legend just
announced a Taylor Swift is the mega
mint around the voice this season what
yeah she's the mega mint I don't watch a
voice but she's the mega mentor for
season 17 and him and Blake Sheldon just
announced it on Instagram that's very
excited yeah she actually like would be
a good mentor like she's actually he's
like [ __ ] smart you know yeah yeah
there are some people who go on the
voice and while like they're great
musicians like I don't know how good
advice Gwen Stefani can give you know so
she has shipped is like a songwriter a
performer and I probably means that
we're gonna get performances too yeah
which is very exciting
good stuff good stuff thanks for sharing
interesting sorry Evan was I going off
in the comments that's good exciting
stuff yeah that would be our fifth story
so now our sixth story is that a
California woman
dreamed about eating her engagement ring
and woke up to find that she really did
I'm Tuesday Jenna
Evans was on a high-speed train that was
racing down the tracks her fiancee by
her side when some bad guys appeared she
said there was only one way to protect
her 2.4 carat engagement rings swallow
it
so that's what she did quote I popped
that sucker off put it in my mouth and
swallowed it with a glass of water then
she woke up evans was relieved on
Wednesday morning that the whole episode
had just been a bit bizarre dream that
she told today was very James Bond that
is until she realized her engagement
ring was no longer on her finger Evans
has a history of sleepwalking soon
realized that while the bad guys and the
high speed train had all been her
snoozing subconscious the consumption of
her engagement ring was not look at this
x-ray ah so how'd you get it out you
just [ __ ] it out uh no I think they
perform surgery she went to the doctor
she got an x-ray and they saw the ring
the gastroenterologist promptly
performed an upper endoscopy which is
the insertion of a small camera and
device down someone's throat okay guys
she wrote I waited a long time for that
damn engagement ring and I will marry
Bobby Howell dad this is such a weird
bunny story really weird funny story I
just saw it oh my god people do crazy
[ __ ] in their sleep yeah this is a crazy
thing I've ever heard you two I'm really
thankful I'm not one of those people
like who like the lines are blurred
between like sleep and dream and I'm
just I'm I'm really happy that I just
sleep like normally
yeah and I'm happy they were able to
like retrieve it and right she didn't
dodged it would have choked oh that - oh
yes she must've had a sip of water and
everything that's just another reason
why you shouldn't sleep with your rings
yeah I don't but Wow
we're like if I wants to do this I would
have to get up and go into my closet to
get it and you know I don't get AB so
right yeah problem solved problem solved
well hope this girl's using Zola for her
upcoming nuptials because it's really
the greatest thing out there yet for the
how a family wedding Zola is a company
that will do anything for love and
they're reinventing the wedding planning
and registry experience to make the
happiest moment in their couple's lives
even happier from engagement to wedding
to decorating your first home Zola is
there combining passionate customer
service with modern tools and technology
Jackie you you so left for your wedding
is that correct yes and I'm still using
it to get out all of my thank-you cards
it keeps such great track of who got me
what and it's just like it's the only
thing that like gives me stability in
these crazy times
you can join over 500,000 couples who
have used Zola
start with a free wedding website it's
so easy and just takes minutes to set up
and customize your zola registry is on
your wedding website so guests can find
wedding info and buy you gifts all in
one convenient place they carry all your
favorite brands when it comes to
registry items like oXXO Cuisinart
Brooklyn and Airbnb couples and guests
love the free shipping smart returns
price matching group gifting and more
can tell you the best part about
registering Lila you can wait to get
something delivered so likewise when we
were moving like you can choose medical
law you can hold off so you don't have
an apartment full of boxes wow that's
actually a genius I think that's my
favorite part of Zola and then when it
comes to paper goods they've got
thousands of designs for every color
scheme their prices are friendly wedding
papers shouldn't blow your budget easily
build your whole suite add Zola from
save the dates and invites today of
paper and thank-you cards build your
free wedding website on Zola and get $50
towards your registry go to Zola comm
slash toast and get started today that
Zola coms eol a.com slash toast
to get $50 towards your registry and get
started today
sign on get married because without the
proper infrastructure it might not
happen and she's a toaster the girl is a
toaster who this who swallowed her ring
how do we know this toaster is getting
married everyone we need that [ __ ] on
the show yeah
Margo she's in California we can do a
Skype interview yeah like on the phone
that is so crazy
and I guess she posted it in the toaster
is like toasters were just making news
always I mean be the right Johnson Demi
lavato thing broken the in the toaster
even um Ruthie story made it to Ryan
Seacrest
Ryan's Tonya rad listen to the show she
the one who told him the story I think
so and ID I'm sure I was like oh my god
I'm listening to you on Ryan Seacrest
and I'm dying I think Ryan was like so
confused he he didn't understand like
how Ruth he got in contact and then he
was referred to us as the morning roast
but thankfully taiga [ __ ] rad
corrected him to the morning toast and
that is just an interesting story that
needs to get out into the masses so
thank you Brian Seacrest and Tonya rod
for having you know good taste yeah and
I feel as though like Jonah's fiance
like knows about Ruthie now because like
how could you not yeah that's other
woman yeah like her friends are
definitely told like she's a New Yorker
all like yeah everyone knows oh my god
injustice
guys well that's half at a time and
that's what I do that's what I've
secretly been wishing for at 11:11 every
day since we started the toast I think
we're he's doing well apparently she's
still in toast your groups she keeps a
low profile obviously yeah you know I
found earn some toast so stupid anyone
to blow up response I do know her last
name
yeah but she's doing she's doing well no
one bother Ruthie yet please like that
what would make this worse for Ruthie
right okay let's jump into some TV
recaps keeping up with the kardashians
was honestly such a good episode it
really was it didn't it feel like two
hours like there was so much like the
birthday party Coachella like the fight
like there were so many parts none of
them were like beeline storylines no it
was all like good [ __ ] yeah I thought
the most interesting part of the episode
was the argument between Kourtney and
Kim and I'm annoyed that they let it go
because I would have liked to have seen
it go further because like Kourtney was
being such effective maybe like I could
it and then her like saying that she
looks like she's wearing a costume in
front of them you glare team while she
was also emailing new Blair yeah that
was bad but it's like how was she to
know like she should have been like you
should tell someone when you're there
and FaceTime in front of other people
oh so I thought if I was so interesting
it was really getting like he did an N
below the belt but then it's like I
actually don't understand this fight at
all because like it's so unrelatable to
have a stylist and people making custom
looks and then they're selling those
custom looks what is the protocol like I
was like I don't know what's who's right
because I don't know what like what this
is and it's like I don't we don't have
stylists so we don't know but like hey
Syd is this stylist on stylists crying
or is it sister on sister crime no it's
a little bit of both like you're
responsible what your staff does should
a stylist be talking to each other
should the sisters be talking to each
other both but I think why Kim got so
upset and why Kourtney couldn't
understand it's like and Kim was saying
she's like nobody understands and what
goes into making one look like it's
endless relationships and endless time
managing those relationships and hours
and hours coming up with ideas I'm like
Kim really prides herself on that like
she's never been seen in the same look
twice every time she steps out of the
house it's literally hours and weeks of
work and Cortney just kind of like
doesn't care and that kind of shits all
over that and then like copies it it's
like I'm knowing you're gonna make fun
of me and then also copy everything I do
like it's frustrating and I totally see
that
and then like Kourtney getting all
defensive being like I don't even care
about Kim's opinion like let's call
Kendall and then like wearing the dress
off of Kim's back right you know
Kourtney's just like so
we hypercritical and I think it's just
because she feels like um like
irrelevant in that in those types of
conversations like I know League
designers are clamoring you know at
Courtney's door looking for
collaborations whereas I Kim everyone
wants to be yeah on Kim's body and that
must make Kourtney feel like lesser you
know it's like she wants to be above it
but she also like cares but she pretends
like she does yeah because she does have
style she's always like taking Instagram
photos and like serving looks but it's
like she just wants to pretend like that
just happened and that's like not
important to her and there's no effort
that goes anywhere this throw this
vintage sure dress yeah and it's like
watching her get ready for her birthday
party and like I know it's like a big
deal but like trying on dresses for
weeks like all those dresses she tried
on work for perfect I think like it's
like I get like go to Bloomingdale's
like finally like it's just getting so
crazy
yeah and to be honest like of all the
dresses she tried on I didn't like that
Donatella one at the end I best like I
don't know what they're looking for like
when she wore that pink Vinci George
kept saying hey Michelle so [ __ ] cute
so cute
also that first dress that was all like
discs silver discs so cute yeah and that
little that long gold sheer dress like
so here yeah but Kim said everything was
ugly and I just I don't I didn't
understand why yeah they're cute maybe
they just weren't like cool and I like
special enough or like new enough like
actually all those other dresses she had
tried on we're like plays off of
existing looks and especially when she
put on that feather dress that like I
literally wore to my 24th birthday
wasn't that wasn't original that was
like an hmm you know yeah so I
understand why at that point Kim was
like what am I doing here peacock right
but how many times do we had to listen
to court you have a conversation about
her freaking out for weeks she was
rubbing my legs and away she was talking
to Jonathan Shay mine she was talking
Chloe in the car I heard four hundred
times that she was freaking out for
weeks and the day I woke up and she was
just fine
yeah she's really getting on my nerves
like I can't stand her she's really
getting on my nerves and like she's
she's just like not being a good sense
no and also like you're grown and she's
like I can't believe Kim was saying this
to me on my birthday first of all it
wasn't your birthday yet and I hate when
people who are [ __ ] grown-ass women
act like their birthday like they're six
years old
yeah like get over yourself [ __ ] okay
yeah but um other than that Kendall made
a few appearances in the episode
just don't understand the dynamics with
with Kendall and Kylie like being in the
show like do they get paid or not
because Kendall is never on I feel like
maybe Kylie just doesn't get paid
anymore and I think Kendall has to show
up every couple and I think Kendall
still gets paid so like she has to go to
South also when Kim was relaying to Kris
the fight with Kourtney like Chris was
[ __ ] smiling like that's how you're
supposed to act no she was being psych
she was like living for the drama no
totally Thank You manatorian ho yeah and
Chris was like that was like really
crazy when she was like you think you do
things for the world but you don't do
anything for the world like those are
some real last fight yeah but I kind of
get that it's like Kourtney takes this
moral high ground over everyone like
being the Kim there are people that are
dying and like she's always just like
making Kim feel stupid for for caring
about superficial things when in reality
what the [ __ ] just Kourtney Kardashian
do for the world when Kim's like
actually I'm here helping people a
hundred percent
don't take that moral superiority over
Kim who's actually [ __ ] doing
something I completely was on one side
the whole time
oh wait on Kim's side but it was just
like the fights are getting crazy now
I'm like this stylist like I'm stylist
crime is so crazy and like the fact that
they like talk [ __ ] to the other
stylists like in front of the other
stylists yeah yeah that was crazy like
Danni Michelle she Styles Erika Jayne
and she also saw Stasi and now she I
think she started working with Courtney
and now she has beef with Kim no I know
it's like she's just a girl trying to do
her job
yeah and I feel like they need like a
head stylist of the sisters right
because look and we have 20 stylists
should not be sending an email to me
Blair like everyone knows me Blair is
Kim yeah but also it's like I feel as
though they always want their looks to
sync up so they should have better like
communication and this Chuck but they
don't have the same stylist I think they
didn't have order no I think that
happened with Kanye like over you like
redoing Kim's whole look like she needed
her own stylist and then they all went
off and just did their own thing yeah
and like a one's house can only do so
much I think they would just get like
too diluted and then it's like
everyone's working so hard on their
outfits for Courtney's party and Chloe
wears the same dress she order her mom's
birthday party and I want to know why no
I respect you first of all I'm all about
outfit repeating shamash she looked
amazing and that's like what you should
that's what you should do that's like
I'll have a dress that I love and I wore
it a few years ago now I'm gonna wear it
again like but it wasn't a few years ago
I was like last year no it was it was a
few years ago it was a Gatsby theme it
was
yes and like Chris isn't 60 anymore oh
um I think but no I just wish she had
like acknowledged it like that she was
like laughing about it because it was
weird to see right now and it's like the
whole conversation of the episode was
around what we're wearing to the party
like she just could have at least
acknowledged it yeah I agree
um and then next week's episode looks
kind of crazy with Scott yelling at
Corey yeah Chuck I look forward to it
it's actually getting so good I'm so
glad they're back like this week on it's
just like the hit of the fam that I need
every week and you know storyline I'm
like really over and if I never hear
about Tristan Thompson again like I'll
be okay like I don't care oh I know
look they're their attempt to co-parent
like call me when it's good like I don't
care I know but it's also so weird that
like Tristan that true like wants to
call her dad and then it's you and then
Co he's left on the phone it's just like
it's embarrassing sure subject it was
really funny I agree I know you don't
watch Potomac but for the people who do
I just want to like give a couple
thoughts about the reunion like the
Potomac ladies like they know that
they're elevated like they looked so
amazing they all were white and they
just looked they all look so good
Ashlee's headpiece was just not working
for me monique is not pregnant anymore
and I've come to realize that she might
be the most beautiful most beautiful
housewife on any franchise Giselle is
touching on these hoes if she is just
she's the Beyonce of the group I'm sorry
Karen huger I'm now watching season one
Karen huger and now we're in the season
three reunion I just want to say like
she saw herself on TV and fixed her like
entire look like she wears a wig now her
she got Botox she like cut the size of
her forehead in half like she looks so
completely different but like she looks
[ __ ] snatched um
Candice I know nobody likes her but like
I still kind of like her except the
drama with her mom I don't appreciate
but she's also really beautiful and then
Oh Robin you know I like Robin even
though everyone accuses her of being
like broke I do really like her
um and I just thought it was a good
reunion and Andy's having so much fun I
can't believe that
Giselle's back with Jamal that's it good
stuff
yeah and then the Comedy Central Roast I
didn't watch it and I don't want to put
things in your head but it was very
interesting
and I just have thoughts on so many
people I only watch the first hour and a
half because you know it's two and a
half hours and it's literally five
minutes commercial two minute
WrestleMania I bet it's Marshall it was
painful to be watching live but I was
spending really interesting and
confusing the people that they choose to
roast like some of them are
comedians and some of them are just
people who Alec knows and like most of
them don't even know Alec and I thought
the the crew was super weird but they
all did for the most part a really good
job I have to say the biggest shock of
the night and she went first which is
the hardest because people forget about
her Nikki Glaser
she was [ __ ] hilarious and she's like
so cute and pretty and like everyone in
there respects her she gets to go to
every roast like she is a female like
she was one of the only female comedian
on that side of the stage and she did
better than anyone Blake Griffin
obviously had jokes written by for other
people by other people for he knew that
he does stand-up though Oh does he
actually makes sense because he had
great delivery apparently that he has
like a little bit of stand-up that he
like likes to do oh that's interesting I
don't think he wrote the jokes but I do
think that he delivered them really well
and they were funny and the kendall
Jenner of it all was like interesting
and they kept targeting back to that Ken
Jong um was really funny everyone kept
referring to him as a guy with little
dick from hangover and now I'm thinking
was that his real penis did we see it
yeah and it was like a child's like I
thought was her prosthetic but now
everyone's talking about it I think it's
not um he was like being so weirdly
serious like he was really just so
honored to be there to performing for
Alec Baldwin and I like he wasn't funny
like he was literally being so serious
like it was weird and then Chris I love
him me too
Chris Reid no that's that's Scott
Disick's friend Chris Redd he's on SNL
they were joking that like you might not
know him cuz he literally never goes on
SM Ellen Alec Baldwin now playing Trump
takes up more of his time on SNL he was
like I thought the most decorated
comedian like he's honest and now like
he is just like it's a comedy album and
he was so disappointing like I literally
do not laugh and he talks like me like
talk really fast I didn't understand one
word he said that must be how people
feel when they listen to me talk
I was really lucked out by him I didn't
see Jeff Ross because I turned it off
but I will be rewatching Ireland Baldwin
made a surprise cameo cameo and she was
[ __ ] great
Alec Baldwin like every basically what
they were saying Alec Baldwin like all
the jokes were like he's a terrible
father his new wife is a child um he he
is a verbally abusive and all around
just like a terrible person like the way
he was reacting to some of the jokes
like it was really making me
uncomfortable like he was I trying so
hard to be like be able to laugh and be
selamat but he wanted to [ __ ] punch
someone in the face
okay he's too important he was super
aggressive sitting next to Robert De
Niro and Robert De Niro is actually a
raisin like he is the oldest man alive
and that was what everyone was saying
about him men was Caitlyn Jenner and the
entire time I was they were being
[ __ ] brutal to her like I couldn't
understand why in God's green didn't
lead Ali earth she would show up like it
was her saw for any woman to be on a
roast like you're a [ __ ] hero but for
a trans woman like in the comedy space
like I just I didn't understand and then
she gets up there and first of all she
was terrible like awful the jokes were
horrible but at the very end I finally
understood why she got there she stood
up there and she said I'm sure a lot of
you were wondering like what I'm doing
here being ridiculed all night and I
just want you guys to know like as a
trans woman if I could sit up here and
be like so nasty and like literally
vilified and and being ridiculed to the
nth degree to any trans person watching
like whatever you're dealing with is
fine like you'll get through it and I
actually appreciated her addressing why
she was there because it made no [ __ ]
sense and actually thought was a really
sweet sentiment and the midst of all
this terribleness then there was Adam
Carolla who do you have any idea who he
has a the name is familiar is that Adam
knows everything no he has like a huge
pot I mean either Lee is a huge
broadcast but like I'd never seen it
stay so far but I know like the Adam
Carolla Show it's like a really big
podcast he was so incredibly boring like
I can't believe people like that get the
opportunity to be on those kinds to say
just like it's actually not fair yeah
and then the weirdest person they had
was I don't know her name but she played
the aunt one of the ants in Sabrina the
Teenage Witch
Oh Zelda I believe yeah I've seen ray
yeah I know the auntie Cosima right
something like that
she was pretty funny in the Curan Alec
Baldwin are like actually really good
like friends weirdly enough um and she
was like a fine addition I didn't see
Robert De Niro go yet and I didn't see
Jeff Ross but other than that I think I
saw everyone else and they just find
comedy roasts to be like so fun and
exciting like it's live like there's not
all right you know and oh but like it's
filmed live that's why it's two and a
half hours okay Ireland Baldwin was in
the audience or catching Ireland's like
you know it's exciting but they really
need to cut it down like two and a half
hours I would say over an hour of
commercials maybe more well they're
making money torture torture talk about
how many [ __ ] commercials at the new
nachos
they come in shredded
um indeed but the nachos are meal oh my
god I saw the commercial one hundred
[ __ ] times I was getting like going
stir-crazy in my house sounds delicious
yeah honestly I was singing that those
nachos sounded really good yeah well I
think that's all she wrote for today I'm
gonna watch um tall girl yes yeah and I
want to see how slurs made me today look
at a matinee I'm also struggling to get
through the newest episode of Dallas
like I don't know why yeah I'm about to
be on my third there's a roast very
similar to the Comedy Central Roast
except nobody's listening it's actually
frustrating to see the people in the
back of the party like no not one
person's paying attention it was so loud
oh [ __ ] okay I have to finish it and
then tonight we have bachelor in
paradise
below deck it'll be a good night oh yeah
paradise isn't on tonight Dan Smith
starts tonight I'm gonna die
oh also some breaking news that I
thought we should talk about on the
Bobby bone show this morning Lauren
Elena was doing press for Dancing with
the Stars and she not said her boyfriend
John Chris broke up I know when I was
really shocked because they were
together like yesterday at her dad's
house and like it's someone who's just
been like there from the beginning like
I hung out with them like I feel
personally like I'm upset I didn't get
like a no or anything you know yeah look
not affected but that's upsetting across
the board but I'm deaf I actually am
going to watch chancinite it's the best
show I watched one season and I'm sorry
[ __ ] but I want to see Lauren Elena
I want to see Hannah brown I want to see
Khurram oh look I actually they're gonna
watch it no it's a very ancient make it
all the way to very and I mean if the
people that I don't like get it out that
I'm done but no one should be fun
Natalie and I they have such good songs
yeah and then they have people come and
perform too so it's it's just it's
animation sweet thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning trust
millenia morning show my chore is back
I'm leading Wednesday for Portland
tickets available Seattle sold out
Vancouver tickets available girl with no
job calm the more new toast livestreams
every Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so please feel
free to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up leave a comment or else
available anywhere podcast can be found
that's Spotify iTunes stitcher all the
places public radio so feel free to
leave a review there subscribe over
there another five star review there we
love you we hope you have a great day
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast happy Monday goin lunch
waring submerge today we have some new
merch shopping soon so start saving up
get those piggy banks ready
you